hi I'm Patrick Lee from dear Pat middle
school and in fifth grade and my
question is do you think hydraulics
could help people with knee problems
when their need breaks down and it could
help it go down much softer well meet
Patrick let me start by saying that is a
fabulous Thai way to go man looks good
you know people people are skeptical to
pink I like the pink I like the purple I
think it's good good choice that is a
great question could hydraulics help
somebody's knees there's a great word
they use in medicine a prosthetic I mean
an artificial limb I got to say yes
absolutely I don't know how familiar you
are with hydraulics but you asked about
it but the idea is hydro is the word for
water and hydraulics use fluids which do
not compress very much water hardly
compresses at all if you squeeze it but
hardly anything happens and the same is
true of the oil in the transmission of
your cars and the oil that's in the
Pistons the shock absorbers of the car
and it's very reasonable that this would
work because what hydraulics do that is
so fabulous is they provide a tremendous
amount of force from a small object to
small actuator and the other thing they
really help with is what's called
damping which used to be called
dampening but the the faster you move
something the more damping slows it down
it's it sounds tricky but it's not
you've you've done it so what happens in
a hydraulic actuator they'll have an
opening which is another I think it's a
Greek word an orifice and so when you
try to squeeze the oil or the water
through that opening it slows it down
and the faster you try to go the more it
slows it down and this has to do with
the nature of fluids and there's a whole
study in physics called fluid mechanics
but yes you should that is a great idea
you're going to be an inventor Patrick
way to go man let me tell you I used to
work at Boeing on the 747 airplane which
is getting to be an old airplane now but
the president still flies around on a
seven
47 it's a Boeing plane like a 757 767
737 787 anyway the thing there's two
things I worked on a lot one of them was
a rudder and that's the thing that
steers the plane this way and that thing
is so powerful so there's a pump by
there's four pumps by the engines and
each pump is unbelievably reliable and
just they work for years and years
because the thing they pump is oil so
they're always getting lubricated
they're always slippery inside which
keeps things from wearing out anyway
those pumps make 3,000 we used to do all
do it in English units pounds per square
inch as they say if you want to move a
house if you want to move the Washington
Monument that far in a 20th of a second
a 747 rudder actuator will do it for you
and so that is a great idea man you can
get so much force in hydraulics and an e
could be the perfect place where and I
just notice when you go to do it you're
gonna need a place for the actuator to
push and you're gonna need something to
pull with like in this in my day I'm
sure it still is this is called a
wishbone crank because it's kind of like
a wishbone you're gonna need a force and
you're gonna need a lever something
that's not quite in the same axis as the
force you'll figure it out that's a
great idea Patrick be an inventor change
the world nicely done
okay you know what patio but you got
someone in your life who needs an
artificial knee help him or her out way
to go
[Music]